annihilation is a new sci-fi movie based
on a book by Jeff Vandermeer it's about
an alien place that grows and mutates
and about the people who it changes it
explores themes of life and death raises
some cool mysteries and builds on the
ideas of the book the story follows an
expedition into the mysterious area ex
wilderness surrounded by a strange
border called the shimmer anyone who
enters doesn't return and the border is
growing the team in the movie includes
the biologist Lena the psychologist
Ventress and the scientists Josie Kass
and Anja together they enter the area
and they find mutant life-forms like
these colorful growths and strange
hybrid creatures like a plant with
different species of flower an alligator
with teeth like a shark and a man with
slithering snake like guts there are
plants growing in human shapes and a
mutant bear creature that speaks with
casas voice after it killed sir so the
area makes new life forms by merging
existing ones together but there's also
duplication making copies of things
there's a mutant deer that mimics
another deers movement there's a double
of leaner which copies her movement on
her face and we learned that Lena's
husband Kane who returned from area X is
actually an alien copy of the real Kane
who committed suicide the area
duplicates other stuff too like by the
end of the movie Lena gets a tattoo that
she didn't have at the beginning it
starts out as a bruise but develops into
this aura Boras design a copy of that
same tattoo on Anya and on this dead guy
the aura Boris symbolizes a cycle of
life and death there's also a house in
Area X that looks just like Lena's place
back home so the area doesn't just
duplicate animals it duplicates images
and even places based on memories the
area effects light and radio and
magnetism it affects the team's minds
and it even affects time the team loses
a few days at the start so the area
distorts duplicates merges mutates and
creates in a process Josie calls
and it all seems to come from some alien
presence in this lighthouse the movie
shows that it's something
extraterrestrial
there are shots of a meteor coming from
space and hitting the lighthouse leap
don't know what the alien wants or if it
wants at all the movie suggests it's
like a cancer unthinking cells that just
grow and spread so while the alien in
his movie represents growth the humans
represent self-destruction
Ventris says almost all of us
self-destruct
it's coded into us each character hurts
themselves somehow Josie cuts herself
Anya is an addict Ventress has cancer
and enters the area as a sort of suicide
Lina has an affair with her do she work
colleague who she hates which hurts a
relationship with her husband Kane who
she loves and Kane knows about Lina's
affair which might be partly why he
volunteered for a dangerous mission to
area X even this tattoo represents
self-destruction
it's a snake eating itself destroying
itself so the humans in this movie
self-destruct and this is actually how
they beat the alien in the end Lina
gives a grenade to the alien double
that's mimicking her she teaches it to
blow itself up and the alien learns this
self-destruction because that's its
function to duplicate and assimilate it
assimilates its own annihilation so the
double burns and takes the lighthouse
and shimmer down with it
humanity beats the alien not through
heroics or strength but through our own
flaws and weaknesses at the end of the
movie Lina reunites with Kane who she
now knows is actually an alien clone and
the Kane asks whether she is really Lina
the movie ends with Lina's eyes glowing
bright which implies some kind of alien
juju so maybe this Lina is actually an
alien clone maybe the Shema didn't
really fall it just expanded to include
the whole world the ending is
deliberately ambiguous but this Lina
probably is the real Lina because we saw
the mimic laner burn and the real Lina
had been in
affected with glowing mutation from
early on that glows nothing new so the
ending might not mean that Lina is an
alien it means that human Leena has
changed
she told the alien had a self-destruct
maybe the alien taught her to grow so
the movies and exploration of life and
death growth and change the book
explores similar ideas but the story is
quite different like area X in the book
doesn't create much new Mutant life it's
more about assimilation people who enter
the area are transformed to become a
part of the natural environment so
there's a dolphin with a human eye and a
fox made of human cells as well as these
creepy plant people the area absorbs
everything into itself and it spreads by
expanding the border and by sending out
clones to replace humans the mimicry and
doubling is maybe like a camouflage used
to hide at slow growth to replace
everything with an alien copy the book
hints that there's some kind of
intelligence behind this like in the
movie the lighthouse has a spooky HR
Giger alien basement but the book has a
whole tunnel structure separate to the
lighthouse it's like an alien upside
down copy of the lighthouse and it has a
long spiral staircase descending down
with fungus forming words on the walls
it reads where lies the strangling fruit
that came from the hand of the sinner I
shall bring forth the seeds of the dead
and it goes on and on like that it's as
though the alien is trying to absorb
human ideas as well as human bodies the
spiraling shape of the words looks kind
of like DNA and the border is like a
cell wall membrane so the whole area
seems kind of like a biological cell
which lends itself to the cancer
metaphor a tumor growing on the world in
the book none of the characters have
names they just called the biologist the
psychologist anthropologist and surveyor
their relationships are more cold and
suspicious the psychologist uses
hypnotism to control the others makes
them forget things and limits what they
the government agency the southern rage
is super mysterious and manipulative
they lie to the group withhold
information it's almost like they're
experimenting on the expedition members
as much as on the area and the
protagonist the biologist is a
complicated highly introverted character
she's sometimes an unreliable narrator
who misleads the reader so the book is
super psychological tense and paranoid
but it's also about the environment for
all the drama and mystery the story is
also a love letter to the beauty and the
strangeness of nature so if you want to
go deeper into area X you can listen to
the annihilation novel now for free at
audible.com/asap look of your choice
with a free trial and they have
thousands of audiobooks on offer if
you've already read annihilation you
might like the little-known Game of
Thrones series and it's spin-off books
like Duncan egg in the world book to
check amount sign up at audible.com
slash ASX or text ASX to 500 500 thanks
to matty asthma for this light house
artwork and thanks to the patrons
including skyler Rudovsky
candace brook matt Hankel and kick
master she is
you